sous son bras une médaille en or
un livre est surtout un précieux
document
la recette du célèbre biscuit pourquoi
avez vous décidé d'apporter la recette
originale du biscuit parce que c'est un
geste emblématique mais ce produit comme
vous le savez a été créé à nantes
il a été créé par mon grand-père louis
lefèvre utile en moins de cinq minutes
l'opération est validée le dépôt
consignés dans sentant une personne
découvrira la recette parmi les objets
déposés dans cet espace
à ce jour les ingrédients sont connus du
grand public pas le dosage à les
proportions et sans secret d'après ces
salles que nous ne serons pas vous ne
serez pas et vous ne saurez pas non plus
comment fabriquer un petit beurre génial
si curieuse de devoir la recette
vous connaissez les proportions vous
maintenant un petit peu j'ai jeté un
coup d'oeil et oui oui discrètement le
célèbre biscuit été fabriquées
dans l'ancienne usine nantaise en 1885
bientôt 115 ans qu'espérez-vous pour les
générations à venir
celui ci contre à la recette ravis de
pouvoir fabriquer lui même ses biscuits
ou pas il la compare avec la recette du
moment à savoir si elle a évolué c'est
un moyen de se mesurer
mais c'est pas autre chose c'est surtout
intéressant d'avoir des traces